once I realized whatever I wanted to do
with Cherie I would go home and just
study the script and then new lines and
new ideas would come about and I take a
little sticky sticky note thing and make
more ideas so as a collaborative thing I
try things out and set all the time
maybe on the spot we would come up with
lines and then just try it out and
whatever you see is is is there you know
but the thing about it is honestly
speaking I didn't go in to black panther
trying to be funny I didn't go into a
lot of time for trying to be like the
funniest person on the set I just went
into it like there's this kid she's
smart she's a princess she makes amazing
technology she's just ultra cool and she
picks on her brother and I just took
that bit of being a real sister that has
a big brother who you pick on I took
that so seriously so everything she says
she's not trying to be funny and I'm not
trying to be funny I'm just trying to be
real like there's some moments where
she's like oh my god don't do this to do
this I can't sell you guys um but but
she's so be yeah you know maybe she's
being real or like picking on him it's
like what's going on they're like she's
just being real and the audience lost
and that's fun and that's amazing
[Music]